hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner again and today
we're showing off the new arcade effect
and be hopping into the arcade the first
one is fluffy 5et linguist that's the
term I don't know play these pages
easily my highest character right he's
starting to fight a black prior solid
stuff there's no modifiers just your
standard 1v1 that's real good that's a
good way to ease into black prior also
you can see some black prior gameplay
once he hates me
yeah I picked JJ because he's really
good against you know in a gang
situation you'll one on two one on three
stuff and I'm assuming that's going to
be part of what's happening so just in
case I picked him I could have easily
picked gladiator since he's actually a
higher rank in terms of gear score than
JJ because I believe JJ is 163 and my
glads 180 but I just picked him for that
gang scenario so hopefully we could kill
Lords fr I've already played a little
bit of black prior because of the early
access I was given so amazing stuff from
Ubisoft they're really happy I got that
so I can already kind already kind of
know how to play against him I'm out I
know most of the stuff good flip counter
good shield bash alright he likes to
think that a lot alright that's a lot of
that's a big damage just 26 damage hi
well that's a good start I have to
remember that I'm playing against bots
so I should only get the confirmed
damage that I should be getting so off a
parry I should do the unblockable zone
but never follow up at that light
because you know that'll that'll affect
me a lot that will that would probably
get parried as seen
good block good full block I probably
could have done a top-heavy unblockable
from that I didn't for some odd reason I
completely forgot that that's the
punished for that it's gonna be a slow
attack go parry and there goes Lord's
ever big ledge guy alright first
chapters done nice good start I don't
know how bad this is gonna get maybe
we'll start seeing two black friars and
then three and then four and see I'm
calling it so heavy attacks knock the
opponent back attacks drain more of the
opponent's stamina but the female is
uninterruptible and has more health but
I have a regenerating shield which is
nice and my knock backs also hit them so
I think if I land a heavy attack I'm
going to immediately flow into top heavy
unblockable so I can get that increased
damage I don't know who I'm gonna go for
first I don't know if they're gonna CC
me I'll see how that goes
[Applause]
big screw big Wilhelm scream right there
I'm [ __ ] I'm annoyed that I can't
block this right now holy [ __ ] he's
pounding me there we go
I probably should execute her to get
that extra health what a shame
I'm gonna wait like four seconds and see
if my shield comes back I don't know if
my show can go past this but well I
think this is all I'm getting oh my gosh
even at the zone Oh heads up I forgot a
diaper armor oh wait I forgot no she
just has hyper armor oh my god I'm such
a [ __ ]
that's Gigi hi well so that's good
there's a spike trap right there or
whatever the [ __ ] it's called um that's
really good to know I screwed up so much
I missed it and I missed a out of
stamina punished but they liked to do
heavy faints they liked to do the
unblockable heavy and fainted so just be
aware with that you don't want to get
caught with the guard break a dude I'm
telling you that I'm calling this right
now
three Blackfriars so now one does more
attack one does more block damage and
one inflicts bleed to me I gained health
unsuccessful attacks and I'm
uninterruptible so this is gonna be
really fun for JJ the fact that he has
like a [ __ ] ton of damage and he can now
he cannot just be he's just cannot be
stopped
what why did you switch God's stances on
me game come on bro
eat my [ __ ] dick holy [ __ ]
oh my god the dead took 20 minutes all
right is therefore okay it's just one
but super buff alright okay
so the trick with that one is you want
to go to the right after you killed the
girl on the right cuz she does the block
damage kill her and then double-team the
other two that is the best way I found
out cuz I kept going to the one on the
left with the bleed that [ __ ] ain't
working okay
now there were 35 minutes into this
recording we can finally stop
ah why'd I do that
you [ __ ] out of you
oh my god he has a revenge that's so
trash was my revenge there it is you're
getting [ __ ] up eat my ass all right
and that was how a warrior ended the
black Pryor's and defeated apollyon
apparently JJ did it all but [ __ ] this
quest all right [ __ ] this quest it's
probably because the new character is
out and I don't know how to use him or I
don't know how to play against him okay
but like [ __ ] these bashes dude I
thought this wasn't gonna be a problem
this is it these are these guys are
[ __ ] oh I I was struggling so much
during this fight I'm so glad I got this
thing though what is I got it for the
idol looks cool I've already stated this
in a past video that it's literally the
same as the other effect I'm putting
this on it's exactly the same as where
is it
I don't have in a lot nope it's not on
the Wulin it's the exact same effect
that the Knights and the like oh it's a
it's a previous mythic outfit I found it
the the name of the outfit is called
Solaris
I don't actually know what the effect is
called but it's the exact same as this
thing it's literally just this but pink
which is kind of shitty that it's a
little bit of a reskin but I'll take it
catch me not playing that again until I
know how to play against black fire but
thank us for watching the video
hopefully enjoyed this is a 42 minute
recording holy [ __ ] anyway like to be if
you do enjoy subscriber for new I
covered the informational side of
foreigner that being balanced changes
hero updates patch notes leaks updates
new hero stuff if you want to know
everything about for honor I want to be
kept up to date never missed a single
update definitely subscribe to the
channel my guys my two most recent
videos would be on-screen if you guys do
want to check that out and they go so we
have greatest today think of art in this
video enjoy season 9
[Music]